Hey folks! Welcome to my weird background
commanders deckbuilding challenge. Two weeks ago,
I gave the following prompt to my discord server:
build a deck using one of the choose-a-background
commanders you see on screen now, partnered with
a background of the person’s choosing. And, there
were a lot of decks this time around—doing a
first pass-through by myself worked fine last
time so I figured I’d do that again this
time, and, uh… it took awhile. It’s fine,
I had a lovely time looking through 400 decks.
The judging criteria were creativity, cohesion,
and likelihood to produce dynamic gameplay. The
first two of those were the main two—I wanted to
see decks that were cool, interesting, and unique
in some way, and I wanted decks where the command
zone and all other major elements of the deck
felt cohesively tied together into a unified
and functioning package. There’s nothing majorly
wrong with a cohesive deck that’s a little bland
or a funky deck that’s a little all over the
place, but in this challenge I was looking for
the confluence between these two features. After
I had done a first passthrough on the decks,
I discussed the ones that stood out to me
the most with my cohost on the Magic Mirror
Podcast 3/3 Elk and my IRL friend Hans,
and picked out a winner for each of the
five commanders based on their input. So,
this video will be showcasing those decks,
and touching briefly on honorable mentions for
each commander as well. Those honorable mentions
will be featured in their own tab on my website,
linked in the description. Also, I’ll be showing
some fun charts for these commanders as well,
compiled by people in my discord server. Shout
outs to Jack and A Garbage Bag of Human Teeth
for going to the effort of putting that together.
Without further ado, the first commander option
was Alora, Merry Thief, a 3 mana 3/2 with the text
“Whenever you attack, up to one target attacking
creature can’t be blocked this turn. Return that
creature to its owner’s hand at the beginning of
the next end step. This is an interesting card,
because bouncing a creature at end of turn
is generally a significant downside for most
decks and not worth the benefit of giving that
creature unblockable. This commander had the
most submissions at around 100, and people tackled
this in a variety of different ways—some used Ball
Lightning style cards that would otherwise sac at
end of turn, some used ninjas, a lot used Alora as
a way to recycle ETBs, some initiative decks, and
a couple paired Alora with Cultist of the Absolute
and some haste equipments in order to avoid
needing to sacrifice a creature on upkeep. As you
can see on this plot, Izzet Alora decks were most
popular, with Dimir Alora decks falling closely
behind. For a few honorable mentions, we have
a deck based around the card Dawn of the Dead,
a deck that focuses on the card Aether vial
to help with getting creatures back into play,
and a spell-less spellslinger deck—that one is a
funny one and it was a favorite among people on my
discord server. For the winning deck, though,
we have a returning winner—Filthystaxplayer
submitted a Sneak Attack deck, with Guild
Artisan chosen as the partnered background.
Now, the choice to run Sneak Attack wasn’t a
unique one for this challenge—getting creatures
out at a discount to be sacrificed at end of
turn makes sense as a way to utilize Alora,
as was a reasonably popular choice as a
result. However, this deck had a handful
of construction choices that made it stand
out above the rest of the crowd. For one,
its utilization of its background—Guild
artisan wasn’t a widely popular background
in the challenge, but it can be a nice
treasure engine. More importantly, though,
this deck pairs it with polymorph effects—that’s
right, this deck can tutor out a Sneak Attack
effect via one of two effects that remove
a permanent to grab one of the same type,
doing so by polymorphing its own background which
is conveniently castable from the command zone.
This can also work with the treasures produced
by Guild Artisan to polymorph for artifacts,
since Chaotic Transformation can target multiple
permanent types and Reality Scramble can be cast
multiple times via Retrace. These are supplemented
with a handful of tutors that can find instants
and sorceries, enabling the deck to have
consistent access to its key enchantments.
One natural question for a Sneak Attack deck
is “what is being snuck out?” In this case,
there’s a total of 16 creatures of mana value 6
or greater, a pretty robust number. Among these,
some number are your typical cheat deck beaters
such as Ancient Stone Idol and Cityscape Leveler,
but past these there are some more interesting
ones. Balefire Dragon provides a source of
large-scale removal, Knollspine Dragon can allow
for some big draw with creative turn ordering,
and there are also a number of ETB
creatures that can get value turn over
turn with Sneak Attack, including
Tyrant of Discord, Astral Dragon,
and Trumpeting Carnosaur. There’s also
another key top end creature, Nezahal,
and that one can serve as a gesture to a key
subtheme within this deck—flicker. Flicker
cards perform two functions here—as with the
commander, they can recycle ETB creatures,
and they can also flicker a creature put out with
Sneak Attack to keep it around permanently at no
additional expense. This gives the deck a great
degree of flexibility in how hard it wants to
commit to the board, and in how much it wants
to grind value. There’s also a good amount of
redundancy of key types of effect—there are four
total cards that can perform a Sneak Attack like
role, two enchantments and two non-enchantment
cards that are similar enough, and there are
likewise multiple alternative options for
keeping around Sneak Attacked creatures outside
of the command zone. Overall, this is a super
cool deck—great job, again, filthystaxplayer!
Next up, we have Amber Gristle O’Maul, a
4 mana 3/3 with haste and “Whenever this
creature attacks, you may discard your hand.
If you do, draw a card for each player being
attacked.” Naturally, this encourages
a lot of low slung, scrappy strategies,
and this was a commander where an impressive
portion of the decks were low budget decks. All of
my top picks here were less than $150, some a lot
less than that. As you can see from the plot here,
black was a very dominant choice for
a background color among Amber decks,
which makes sense given her self-discard
oriented gameplay. For honorable mentions,
we’ve got a pump spells voltron deck, a budget
aggro deck, and a reanimator deck. For the #1
amber deck, though, we’ve got Lord Reverend’s
clerics and dwarves deck, with Haunted One as
the partnered background. Really, this deck
focuses on one specific variety of creature,
that being clerics and dwarves that sacrifice
creatures to accomplish tasks. We’ve got 11 of
these, along with 12 other clerics and 5 other
dwarves. The basic idea here seems simple—dump
these creatures into play alongside Amber and
Haunted One, and then swing in with Amber in
order to both wheel and use sacrifice abilities
on the now-undying clerics and dwarves. This can
produce effects such as destroying a creature
with Blind Zealot, tutoring out black creatures
with Shadow-rite Priest, and drawing cards with
Skullport Merchant. The deck also contains five
cards that reanimate in some way, including three
attached to a cleric, as well as three madness
cards, so there’s some degree of synergy present
to work with Amber’s attack trigger. Her power
and toughness aren’t great—only a 3/3 on a 4 mana
creature—but this doesn’t matter as long as the
deck has Haunted One in play. This might prompt a
followup question—what if you want to sacrifice a
creature that already has a +1/+1 counter on it?
This solution to this potential issue comes in the
form of a handful of cards that remove counters
from creatures. There are nine of these total,
and while most of these feel more like filler
than anything else, the two enchantments seem
great. Ion Storm provides a quality source
of repeatable burn damage, and Retribution
of the Ancients is an even more potent tool,
particularly when the deck’s board gets bigger.
The other standout element of this deck is
its suite of boardwipes. The deck runs an
eye-watering nine boardwipes, which the deck can
break parity on with through Haunted One. One of
these nine is Jokulhaups, which can provide a
game-warping nuke once the pilot of this deck
trusts their board to run to the finish line.
These board wipes seem like an appropriate tool
to help the deck’s honestly mediocre creatures
get around the large boards of modern-day EDH
decks. Because that’s the most palpable vibe this
deck gives off—the jank factor. The cards here are
at best normally mediocre cards being used in
their narrow use-case window of being decent,
and in some cases mediocre cards even in this
deck. We’ve got late 90s dwarves, various mediocre
commons from across the years, Grimoire
of the Dead—there’s so much nonsense here,
united in flavor or function or both. This feels
appropriate, though, for a few reasons. Amber
is a fundamentally janky commander—she’s a draw
engine, but one that requires playing in a very
scrappy style, and who doesn’t even reward that
style that heavily. Her two creature types—Cleric
and Dwarf—are not generally great ones to build
around. Clerics have gotten just enough love to
make Shadowborn Apostle decks look a quarter
of the way respectable, but dwarves? Yeah no,
forget about it. In addition, this deck’s budget
is quite low—it’s sitting below the $50 mark if
you exclude Haunted One, a card which, as Lord
Reverend alluded to, is basically free as long
as you win this competition, since the prize is an
altered art version of the card. A wildly polished
deck with top tier card quality this certainly is
not, nor was it intended to be. As a final note,
this deck also has an undeniable thematic core
to it. We have themes of death and dying riddled
throughout this deck, including the Haunted One
background, a whole lot of cultist-type creatures
that sacrifice things to perform rituals, and
board wipes that represent great dying-off
events. Lore-wise, Amber herself is a cleric with
connections to the Shadowfell, carrying a certain
degree of liminality with her, tugged between life
and what lies beyond. This further helps the deck
in communicating itself as a cohesive unit, and
the end result has an undeniable sense of panache.
Next, let’s talk about our white commander
option, Ellyn Harbeeze Busybody. She’s a 4
mana 2/4 creature with “Tap: look at the top X
cards of your library, where X is the number of
tokens you created this turn. Put one of those
into your hand and the rest on the bottom of
your library in any order.” People took this
base in a variety of different directions,
but there were two main patterns. One were decks
that create tokens and also really want a source
of filtering, an example of which might be a combo
deck or some sort of synergy hungry machine sort
of deck. The other type of deck people built were
decks more specifically interested in maximizing
the level of dig they could get out of Ellyn,
either through creating a lot of tokens or by
untapping her. As you can see from the pie chart,
most of the decks featured either black or green,
though this was not the case for our honorable
mentions here. These were three blue white decks:
a deck built around flyers and the card
Mirrorweave, a hatebears deck with a lot
of draw-denial effects, and a twiddle-storm deck
built around cards like Talrand, Sky Summoner.
However, winning deck was a different sort of
twiddlestorm deck—atrus159’s Bellringer deck,
with Agent of the Iron Throne as the background.
This is a deck focused on effects that untap
all of your creatures—4 of these untap
all creatures on opposing untap steps,
8 untap all creatures once, and a few other cards
untap creatures more selectively. To go along with
these, this deck has 8 creatures that tap to
create a token, 7 cards that tap to add mana,
and 2 cards that tap to create treasures,
effectively doing both of these things.
Once this deck has Ellyn and some of these
effects online, it can start to do some cool
stuff. The deck can use all tap abilities,
creating mana and tokens and filtering,
and then it can play a card that untaps all
creatures to refresh all these tappers. Mana
creators let the deck avoid running out of
mana too fast, and creating tokens allows the
deck to dig deeper and deeper with Ellyn on each
round of tapping, hopefully finding additional
untapping effects for as long as the Ellyn
player wants to keep going. The deck doesn’t
have an explicit wincon in the 98 outside of maybe
Halo Fountain, but the elegant thing here is that
the deck doesn’t really need a specific payoff
card for a big tapping and untapping turn. Agent
of the Iron Throne in the command zone means
that a board full of tokens already contains
an implied level of damage unless opponents
order their removal just right, and several
Ellyn activations means a well-curated hand of
cards when passing after a big turn. To go along
with the rest of this gameplan, this deck also
contains a handful of one-time token producers,
some protection for the commander, and
a small suite of other support cards.
What’s interesting about this deck is that I
think both Agent of the Iron Throne and Haunted
One work well as backgrounds, though they lend
very different play patterns for finishing off
opponents. Agent of the Iron Throne gives the deck
a more measured playstyle that focuses more on
optimizing twiddle turns in the moment and
worries about winning the game later once
a whole lot of tokens are in play. Haunted
One, on the other hand, is more explosive,
rewarding careful planning and avoiding opposing
hate with the potential for some truly disgusting
alpha strikes. Either way seems valid enough to
me, though something nice about Haunted One is
that it also gives the deck a bit of something
that it’s a bit low on at the moment—protection.
Ellyn can tap herself at any time she’s untapped
to grant the benefit of Haunted One, even if no
tokens were created during a turn, which gives
a pretty sweet tool for dealing with removal.
This is relevant because deck’s strategy—and
its access to a blood artist effect—depend
on Ellyn being in play, and Ellyn getting
single-target removed can pose a meaningful
setback for the deck. This issue is somewhat
counterbalanced by this deck’s high density
of ramp and inclusion of recovery cards such
as Dazzling Theater and Wand of the Worldsoul,
which can help the deck in getting Ellyn back
out on the board rather than stalling out,
so this more an idea to play around with
than any kind of major critique. Overall
this deck is well-built, dynamic,
and unique—great job atrus159!
Next up, let’s talk about Viconia, Drow Apostate.
She’s a 3 mana 2/3 whose text reads “At the
beginning of your upkeep, if there are four or
more creature cards in your graveyard, return
a creature card at random from your graveyard to
your hand.” On the surface, this card is similar
to an enchantment called Oversold Cemetery,
with one key distinction—the returned creature
is chosen at random. This immediately causes
some problems with the use cases of the card,
because if you throw a bunch of filler creatures
into your graveyard plus a desirable key creature
or two, you’re probably gonna get back garbage
off of Viconia, or at least that’s the most
likely outcome per trigger. Naturally, there were
a mixture of different solutions players found to
this issue—some chose to have most creatures be
functionally identical, or chose synergy packages
where getting back any creature was beneficial
regardless of what it was. From this chart you
can see that colors were more spread out with
Viconia than with most of the others, though green
was still the most popular. For a few honorable
mentions, there was an Umori companion-ed Golgari
midrange deck, a modular creatures deck, and
an Astral Slide deck. For the winning deck,
we have a different cycling deck—Chimes’ high
mana value cycling deck, with Tavern Brawler
as the background commander. This was the one
winning deck that 3/3 Elk dissented on, though
they did note that from a lore standpoint having
Viconia drunkenly fighting people is very funny.
As you might guess from the description of the
deck I gave, the foundation of this deck lies
upon one simple fact—there are a lot of 5-6
mana creatures with some form of cycling or
other. This deck contains 13 each of generic
cycling creatures and landcycling creatures,
plus an additional three channel creatures which
can be discarded for an effect. This means the
deck has a pretty easy time getting creatures in
the graveyard for purposes of getting Viconia’s
ability online. In addition, all of these
landcycling creatures can basically exist
in place of a land, so that significantly
lowers the number of lands that need to go
in the deck. The other thing that can help with
this is MDFC lands, at least in the sense that
they allow the deck to contain more cards whose
front side is not a land. This is important for
purposes of Tavern Brawler, since hitting a
land with the card doesn’t buff Viconia. As a
result of its 13 landcycling creatures and its
11 MDFC lands, this deck’s official landcount,
excluding MDFCs, is 14. My manabase tool does
rate this deck’s manabase as “very strong”
after plugging in some appropriate discounts,
and I’m inclined to agree with that analysis,
though the caveat with that is that there will
be lands entering tapped and turns spending mana
landcycling. The end product of this is that
this deck has an eye-wateringly high average
card cost of 4.3, and that’s including lands!
This means that the deck is likely going to be
able to push a decent amount of damage with a
Tavern Brawling Viconia. There are a handful of
evasion cards to help with this, as well as a
decent suite of removal to clear out blockers
or push an opponent into unfavorable blocks. The
other thing accomplished by the command zone is
that it contains two different value engines,
which can allow the deck to maintain a solid
baseline of gameplay volume, even if there are
some setbacks. Finally, the deck has a handful of
other cards which can take advantage of its high
average mana value, in addition to Tavern Brawler.
As it stands now, this deck is a funky midrange
battlecruiser brew with some fun side paths.
However, more so than being a perfectly conceived
final deck, I like this as a deck that has a lot
of good ideas and comfortably dips its toes in a
lot of different archetypes, a deck whose elements
gesture to a variety of different directions
that it could be further honed. More ramp
could amplify the battlecruiser side of it, more
reanimation spells could amplify the explosive
creature-cheating side of it, more evasion
could amplify the voltron elements of this deck,
more discard or other resource-attacking methods
could amplify the grindy aspects of this deck,
and so on. It’s also very budget at the moment,
and could either be kept that way or upgraded
with a handful of more powerful cards. Good
stuff. Thanks for the awesome brew, Chimes!
Finally, let’s talk about our green commander
option. Halsin Emerald Archdruid is a four mana
2/4 with the ability to pay one mana to turn a
token into a 4/4 green bear until end of turn.
This is a great ability in terms of raw rate,
like those tokens were probably something like
base power 1/1 if they were creatures so that’s a
+3/+3 for one mana, and if they weren’t creatures
before that’s a whole different degree of value.
However, despite having a lot of potential, Halsin
also presents a handful of questions. What tokens
should he be animating? And, what should be done
with a bunch of 4/4s? There were some creative
answers to these questions among the submissions.
As you can see on this plot, blue and white were
quite dominant as second colors, constituting
around a third of decks each. For a few honorable
mentions, there was a deck that animated aura
tokens to generate sac triggers off of Martyr’s
Bond, a powerstones deck, and a tokens enchantress
deck that used Opalescence to get an additional
copy of the background bonus. God Opalescence has
good art, can we talk about that? John Avon really
knocked it out of the park with that one. Anyway,
for the winning deck, though, we have CubiCCL’s
incubate deck, with Inspiring Leader used as
a background. Incubate is an unusual mechanic
introduced in March of the Machine that creates
artifact tokens with +1/+1 counters on them, and
these tokens can later be transformed into 0/0
creatures for two mana. This has some very clear
upsides paired with Halsin’s ability—for one,
we get all the benefits of the +1/+1 counters on
the tokens without needing to pay the two mana to
flip them, instead paying 1 mana to get them for
a turn with an additional +4/+4 on top. Secondly,
the fact that these tokens don’t need to be
flipped makes them more resilient—instead of
exploding to either an artifact wipe or a creature
wipe, these tokens will generally only die to
artifact wipes since they’re typically not
creatures on our opponents’ turns. They
also don’t even have to be creatures on your
turn—this deck runs a number of board wipes,
which have the potential to be kinda one-sided
with the deck storing power and toughness.
The deck contains 12 total cards that create
incubator tokens, and with their relative
permanence in mind it also runs a number of cards
that can proliferate the +1/+1 counters on them,
gradually ramping up the size of these tokens
turn over turn. There are also 8 other cards in
the deck that use counters in some way, which is
good as it means that the proliferate cards are
going to be getting value outside of incubators,
of which there aren’t that many due to them only
being in one set. Likewise, many of these cards
that use counters also create tokens, with this
deck containing a total of 16 other token
creating cards outside of the incubate cards,
which is good as the deck’s main plan for winning
is animating things with Halsin and swinging in
with them. The background is here to amplify that
plan, boosting the 4/4 bears up to 6/6 bears. This
buff might be less meaningful in contexts with
an especially large number of tokens, but when
the deck only has a handful of tokens to swing in
with, that size difference can be quite relevant
to the outcome of the combat. As I alluded
to earlier, this deck has seven board wipes,
which further enhance its combat potential. While
the commander isn’t likely to survive a wipe,
the incubate tokens usually will, which can allow
for a nice swing on a following turn, or I suppose
the same turn if the deck has a lot of mana.
Overall, this deck is a well-rounded midrange deck
based around a not-very-heavily-played mechanic
that goes excellently with Halsin. Love to see it!
Alright, those were the winning decks.
I appreciate everybody who participated,
as even though it took a while to go through
the submissions, it’s always super fun to see
what people come up with. You can check out
the honorable mentions in the link down in
the description, and you can also feel free to
let me know in the comments what you thought of
these decks. What was your favorite? Was there
a deck that I didn’t pick that you think was
terribly robbed? You can also let me know if you
have ideas for future deckbuilding challenges,
because these are fun and I’ll probably do
2-3 more later this year. With that said,
thanks for watching! And thanks to my Patrons
for supporting my work on this channel. If you
want to join them, a link to my Patreon is down
in the description, and I greatly appreciate the
generosity of all those who contribute.
Alright, that’s all for this one, bye.